- Don't worry.
I'll guide you through it.
It's just like
riding a hover bike.
You guys have hover bikes?
[DRAMATIC INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
These train things, that--
that's magnetic
levitation, right?
Obviously.
Obviously-- but I've never
seen it this efficient.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here are your communication
devices for Korea--
unlimited range, also equipped
with audio surveillance system.
Check these out: remote
access kimoyo beads.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fully automated, like
the old American movie
Baba used to watch.
Mmm.
And I made them
completely sound absorbent.
Interesting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHS]
Delete that footage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: Remote
piloting system activated.
My god.
[EXHALES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ENGINE STARTS]
Yes, yes, yes!
ANNOUNCER: Remote
driving system activated.
[TIRES SCREECHING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ooh.
The entire suit sits within
the teeth of the necklace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ah!
Whoo!
Let's go!
[SKIDDING]
[GRUNTS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]